is there a grooming process for the
Hollywood System is there a certain type
it seems like I see anyone in the
Hollywood System is ultra
whereas in a film people
they might be more introverted but you
think to cross over to the Hollywood
System you almost have to be that larger
than life
persona probably yeah I mean I have some
of the people I've seen get stuff done
their main challenges confidence they'll
walk into a room with an argument that
makes no sense and they know it yeah and
there are 12 really smart people sitting
in that room and we're going into that
meeting the other person makes their
case I'm sitting there and I'm thinking
that makes no way out yeah they'll
figure out but that doesn't make any
sense and after 10 minutes these 12
smart people are convinced they gonna
we're doing exactly but we're walking
out and I'm asking the other person do
you know that what you just said Nick no
centimeters right yeah no but he is
currently in town just threw his
confidence yeah so I think there is
something to that that it's got to do
with budget again the Hollywood doesn't
want to put people in charge the
doubters yeah but the problem is that
creative people are doubters but that's
their thing you know so you really kind
of had to switch and put on the other
half and pretend unfortunately for those
it's a sales meet
do you have to sell to them that you are
the one who has the solutions and span
theater then come up with a solution so
you're constantly selling something that
you don't yet have you know which to me
was in the beginning really weird before
we shot my second film the day before
the first shooting day they gave me a
sheet and it had all the territories on
it that the movie had already been sold
to it had already been sold to Russia
and to Malaysia and true italy and spain
and i said that we have a charter lluvia
you know nolan know that we already had
commitments 2000 theaters there and that
territory ba-ba-ba-ba-bom and we haven't
shot a frame of the movie so let's just
what hollywood is based on hollywood is
is selling these promises you know and
then you try to live up to it and then
at some point the hype takes over and
almost doesn't matter and it helps
problem if the product can actually
support what the hyper
the hype is such an industry in itself
that it carries by I had the things some
people we were working with were so
great at the PR thing that they could
have you know marketed a cookie in two
thousand theaters I want to work and
until the audience realizes what they've
been sold its to make that already
bought their ticket here it's a whole
art form in itself
you